it's been 20 minutes since the start of
this round you came yesterday into the
studio you said that finally you have to
pick things up and start winning games
and you did just uh that what are your
initial thoughts after this uh yeah
I wanted to win some games but I didn't
expect it
uh yeah I mean very uh unusual of course
I think I haven't won a game like this
in in 20 years or something but this is
of course a well-known trick in this
line and uh okay he uh elshon doesn't
play the Petrov usually
so I figured that he prepares something
in rookie one on my bd2 here instead of
C4 which is the line that I that I
played in in a couple of games before
so I I was trying to pick a different
line so that he
would not be able to use his preparation
and just get a normal position but uh of
course there is this trick in this line
and uh when when he was sinking after C4
I uh I was very happy because I thought
that they made the right choice at least
he has to uh to think or at least to
remember some of his preparation but
when he went Castle then I suspected
that he might might have just missed
this history what was your reaction when
you saw him touching the king and going
for Castle because after taking on D5
you're already closer yeah this is
already like a huge Advantage here so
yeah I mean after he was thinking when I
play C4 I I mean I wasn't expecting of
course that he would play this but uh
but I knew that somehow he would uh he
he was not that familiar with with the
position and uh but of course Castle was
uh was a huge surprise and then he took
on D5 you realize at this point after
taking on D5 that his loss or uh no I
think it was after I took going forward
that he he realized
um but uh yeah I mean after you play
castle is uh of course I strongly
suspected that he was going to take on
the fight because you don't play castle
in order to play an id6 or or remove did
he think about taking on D5 yeah just
for I don't know maybe just 30 seconds
30 seconds yeah something like that so
it was his intention to transpose to the
main line of course but he was not sure
what's the best way and and he thought
probably that after Queen takes D5
rookie 196 it is the the line that he
wanted to play but uh but it just
doesn't work in this move order yeah
yeah absolutely linear I mean what else
can be said about the game
congratulations uh that's a huge victory
for you
um to enter the second half of the event
now since there's only 20 minutes since
the start of uh the round we're gonna
work you a little bit
let's take a look outside no free day
for you a little free day for you let's
take a look at some of the other games
that are happening right now uh Fabiano
also came with this idea Queen C2 take
on uh C4 and E4 do you know anything
about this line yeah I used to play this
line I mean I used to play this laugh as
black and
um and I remember realizing Queen C2
takes of course Queen takes E4 it's the
main line and then Bishop F5 for Bishop
G4 but there is this idea to play E4 and
and and Sack upon like this to b5p3
um have you ever faced it no no I
remember uh analyzing it for for for
black at some point like maybe 15 years
ago but uh but I I don't think I got to
play the line that's black
ever and now we have this position on
the board A6
things are happening quickly Knight to
C3 Castle Knight to C3 of course Castle
is not possible for uh black right now
because after E5 dropped the pawn on H7
so how should the black develop finish
the development in distribution well
usually yeah I mean night goes from D7
Bishop on B7 but this is the type of uh
Pawn sacrifice which is slightly
unpleasant for black you also get some
of those positions in the Catalan and in
some some positions of the Queen's
Gambit were uh yeah white is down upon
but a lot of space you have the center
and you have always this E5 Knight to E4
ideas the black blacks King is always a
little bit uncomfortable in in the
center or even in the king side if the
pawn gets to E5 which it will so Bishop
to B7 is on the board right now yeah and
then probably something like a rook D1
and just black steel cannot Castle
because of E5
so at some point black probably has yeah
we'll probably play some H6 but yeah
even if white goes like Bishop F4 and
just play normal moves
it should be it should be quite uh quite
nice play for white I guess but of
course it's it's uh it's a game it's a
long lasting compensation yeah yeah
let's see the sequence of events that
happen in your game actually and you
take us through this situation uh wow
everybody was flabbergasted what just
happened five minutes did they agree to
a draw what just happened
we see Hands in the back also our
photographers as well it seems like even
our chief Arbiter is stunned he's like
whoa this was not supposed to happen
did they want you after the game
there's no point there's no point in
checking uh
and checking me because it's uh and you
seemed a little bit distraught as as
well what were your emotions right now
no I mean I felt sorry for him because
just to lose a game like this it's just
very painful and after he he's having a
bad tournament and
um you can lose but I mean to lose like
this it's uh it's uh
it's not nice at all so I yeah I I saw
he was really sad but uh yeah it happens
sometimes yeah absolutely this is uh
comparative Sports and these things do
happen guys any questions before we let
the linear go no just uh I want to Echo
your exact thoughts as well linear that
it's been 20 years since I I won a game
in an opening trap at this level of the
national championship this was quite a
gift and go enjoy yourself
yes congratulations yes it was expected
but really nice Victory sometimes it
happens exactly just